Fleisch für alle:
Immer billiger, immer mehr.
Es muss in Massen produziert werden,
in industrieller Großproduktion.
Geschlachtet wird am Fließband – für Fleisch,
das nur wenige Euro kostet.
[Bei] vielen Sachen guckt man ja schon doch
irgendwie auf den Preis, ne?
Also ist das … dann wahrscheinlich der Preis
in dem Sinne
dann schon doch irgendwo vordergründig,
aber wenn man so drüber nachdenkt,
ist natürlich auch schade,
dann ... weil man dann wahrscheinlich
so was dann
wie Massentierhaltung
und Ähnliches alles unterstützt.
Ich find’s auch schade, dass man
ein Tier schlachten muss für zwei, drei Euro.
Also das geht gar nicht.
Ich glaub wir sind sehr,
sehr bequem in unserem Konsum,
und das ist auch ein riesiges Problem,
dass wir einfach ... Wir haben das Angebot.
Es ist billig.
Wir greifen einfach zu,
aber wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht,
was wir im Endeffekt damit anstellen.
Fleisch hat seinen Preis.
Wer billiges Fleisch will, nimmt in Kauf,
dass dahinter großes Leid steht.
Immer wieder decken Tierschützer
katastrophale Haltungsbedingungen auf.
In einem deutschen Schweinemastbetrieb
wurden heimlich Filmaufnahmen gemacht.
Die Schweine sind
in engen Kastenständen eingepfercht.
Auslauf gibt es nicht.
Die Tiere wirken apathisch.
Etliche sind verletzt.
Laut Gesetz ist es zulässig, dass ein Schwein
auf weniger als einem Quadratmeter lebt.
Die Aktivisten vom Deutschen Tierschutzbüro
wollen die Verbraucher wachrütteln.
Sie kämpfen für die Schließung solcher
Schweinemastanlagen.
Für uns ist eigentlich das große Ziel,
am Ende zu sagen:
Wir haben keine Massentierhaltung mehr,
wir haben keine Nutztierindustrie mehr,
und es werden keine Tiere mehr ausgebeutet
nur rein für den Konsum des Menschen.
Der Mensch weiß gar nicht mehr,
was dahintersteckt,
wie so ’n Tier aufgezogen wird,
dass da eigentlich auch ’n Leben dranhängt,
damit dann dieses Fleisch dort liegt, und dass
das eigentlich viel mehr wert sein müsste,
als er eigentlich bezahlt.
Ich glaube, dafür ist das Bewusstsein
einfach über die Jahrzehnte
vollkommen verloren gegangen.
Dieser Fleischer setzt darauf,
dass sich die Käufer bewusst sind,
dass sie eine Wahl haben.
Für viele Menschen ist
Fleischverzehr immer noch ein Genuss,
auf den sie nicht verzichten wollen.
Der Betrieb setzt auf Qualität und
traditionelles Fleischerhandwerk.
Die Herstellung der Wurst dauert länger und
ist aufwendiger als die industrielle Produktion.
Dementsprechend teurer
sind die fertigen Schinkenknacker.
Der Chef der Fleischerei
kennt seine Zuliefererhöfe persönlich.
Wir kaufen hauptsächlich
aus bäuerlicher Haltung.
Das ist uns ganz wichtig,
dass wirklich aus kleinen Betrieben,
die uns allen bekannt sind ...
Das Fleisch hat halt einen wesentlich
intensiveren Rindfleischgeschmack,
den manche vielleicht
schon gar nicht mehr so richtig kennen.
Es hat ’ne ganz andere Zartheit.
In Deutschland kam Fleisch
bis vor einigen Jahrzehnten, wenn überhaupt,
nur einmal in der Woche auf den Tisch.
Erst mit dem sogenannten Wirtschaftswunder
in den 50er- und 60er-Jahren
änderte sich das.
Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts
gab’s natürlich diese Massentierhaltung,
Nutztierindustrie in dem System,
wie wir es heute haben, einfach nicht.
Und das ist heute das größte Problem darin,
dass so viel Fleisch verfügbar ist
und so extrem billig verkauft werden kann,
weil in der Massentierhaltung
einfach Wirtschaftlichkeit
ganz klar über Tierwohl steht.
Das Problem:
Weltweit wollen immer mehr Menschen
Fleisch essen, etwa in China oder Indonesien.
Weltweit isst jeder im Schnitt
45 Kilogramm pro Jahr.
In Deutschland sind es sogar 60.
Die Nachfrage steigt, je mehr die Preise
sinken – auf Kosten der Tiere.
Immer schneller und effizienter
muss Fleisch erzeugt werden.
Die globale Fleischproduktion hat sich in den
vergangenen 50 Jahren mehr als verdreifacht
und liegt aktuell
bei mehr als 330 Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr.
Hochwertige Fleisch- und Wurstwaren
statt Billigfleisch –
seit einigen Jahren liegt das
in Deutschland im Trend.
Mein Appell kann eigentlich nur
an die Verbraucher sein:
Er hat die Macht an der Kasse
und an der Theke, sich dafür zu entscheiden,
lieber einen Tag oder zwei Tage weniger
in der Woche Fleisch zu essen,
aber dafür mehr darauf zu achten,
wo es herkommt und wie es gehalten wurde,
und dementsprechend
auch mehr Geld dafür auszugeben.
Den Appetit auf Fleisch
muss sich niemand verderben lassen.
Die Entscheidung,
was und wie viel er kauft, trifft jeder selbst.